after his college graduation roland haas
was recruited by the cia
serving for 30 years he worked in many
countries including germany iran
afghanistan and india next his new book
enter the past tense describes his life
as an assassin for the intelligence
agency
this is an hour
good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to barnes and noble
for nearly 30 years roland haas worked
for the cia
extracting soviet special forces and
their families from east germany
assassinating international drug dealers
and carrying out other undercover and
clandestine missions as needed by the
central intelligence agency who
recruited him when he was a student at
purdue university in the early seventies
at times he was tortured physically and
psychologically the stress caused him to
turn to alcohol and drugs
in his new memoir and to the past tense
roland shares his extraordinary life as
a cia assassin and recovering alcoholic
a life he's turned around
please welcome assistant deputy chief of
staff and command senior intelligence
officer of the united states army
reserve command roland w huss
[Applause]
thank you uh your reception is certainly
warmer than your weather's been today
you got off the plane from atlanta we
had like six or seven days in a row now
where it's been over 100 degrees and we
hit beautiful new york and it's cold and
it's wet and my wife's complaining she
doesn't have a jacket doesn't have an
umbrella it doesn't have the right kind
of shoe so you're costing me money too
but i'm happy to be here thank you um a
funny thing happened to me on the way to
college
in 1970
as was already said i went to purdue
university i was
accepted there on a naval rotc
scholarship and i was taking the marine
corps option
i was a very gung-ho young kind of guy
at the time
and during that first year i got called
one day by the commandant of the naval
rotc that i was to report to his office
now when you're told to report to the
commandant's office that's never a good
thing you start thinking what did i do
where did i screw up who did i hurt i
got there and he showed me into an
office where there was a gentleman
playing close
would come to talk to me he said from
washington
he had a file on his desk in front of
him and the file was on me it had my
name on it and he started telling me
more about myself
than i'd remember it as a matter of fact
turns out i had also wanted to go to
west point i'd wanted to go to annapolis
and i'd wanted to go to the air force
academy and in the course of all of
these applications and checking around
to these places i had to undergo a
barrage of psychological tests
he had all of that stuff in his file he
had my grades my records from earliest
times
i'd also become pretty much a good
athlete in a lot of different individual
sports and he started talking to me and
he said you know
and on top of it i spoke german and at
the time russian much better than i do
now he said we think you can do a lot
more
for the country
than you could ever do wearing a uniform
whether it's navy marine corps army
whatever
and i said okay keep talking
and he told me that he represented one
of our three-letter intelligence
agencies
and
he thought i would be a good match for
him
he said what i would do is i'd be
working for central intelligence now
this came as a shock because back in the
1970s
there were a lot of rumors about cia
recruitment on college campuses
but you never knew anybody it really
happened to it's kind of like winning
the lottery today everybody knows
somebody wins it somewhere just nobody
knows where who how
and i certainly didn't think it would be
me
we talked for a little while longer
and being
just turning 19
i was very intrigued
and it had kind of a romantic appeal
just the whole word the cia intelligence
espionage so i said fine i'd like to do
that
so i said for the time being i would
continue in my role as a naval
midshipman marine corps cadet
and that when the time came
we would talk further about where that
would go
my first summer of training there after
i did my naval training on the oldest
oiler in the navy fleet the ao32 the uss
guadalupe out of san diego
i went into parachute training high
altitude high opening and high altitude
low opening for those of you who aren't
familiar with that that's when you jump
out at about 35 000 feet
where if you're not wearing special
equipment and goggles your eyeballs
freeze over
and you can't breathe
and i underwent
intensive weapons training weapons
familiarization
things like that
this progressed for another year then
all of a sudden the next spring he said
okay roland it's time
you're ready it's time to go
do what you signed on to do and i
thought great i can do this
but then he explained what that was
going to mean
i could not just leave purdue university
and i could not just resign my
commission
because what they needed for someone to
be truly undercover and i was going to
be used at first for drug interdiction
they needed somebody
who was dirty who at least looked dirty
and here again being naive said okay
what does this mean he said well
you're gonna have to get thrown out of
school
and you're gonna have to get drummed out
of the naval naval rotc the navy
didn't sound too good after that he said
the way you do that is you're gonna get
arrested
that sounded even worse
my parents were german immigrants they
came over shortly after world war ii and
if you're familiar with european parents
one of the biggest joys in their lives
is bragging about their kids my mother
had a huge family everybody's bragging
about my cousins and my father came from
a huge family not only was i about to
take that away from them the fact that
they could brag about me but i was about
to become
a source of intense shame
and upset because nobody turns to the
relatives and says
my son was thrown out of school my son
was arrested
but at that point it's something i had
to do so i was told okay what you do is
you take this camera and this camera
belonged to the naval public affairs
office
and you drive down to indianapolis to
this address it's a pawn shop you pawn
the camera and you come back and wait
pretty soon you'll get arrested camera's
worth enough it's going to be a felony
i did it i drove down came back and
waited
and i waited
and i waited
and couldn't even get arrested they
couldn't figure this out
it got to the point where i had to walk
into the police station and say
did anybody report a missing camera
because i'm the guy who took it
and i'm having these horrible pangs of
conscience and i just want to come clean
police still didn't know what to do with
me at that point i looked like a crazy
man
they sent me home
i sat there and waited and a few days
later ironically right after watching
the godfather with my roommates we went
to the movie theater knock comes on the
door it's the west lafayette police
department
now not only did they take me seriously
but they came with what seemed like the
whole darn police department all of them
in leather jackets this was a big thing
to hit west lafayette indiana
because along with the camera
coincidentally you know i'd also worked
at a bookstore someone had started a
fire at the bookstore and someone had
started a fire in the armory the rotc
armory and stolen weapons
so the police naturally put two and two
together and it must be me
so now i'm not only faced with
felony theft but arson and grand larceny
so i'm sitting in jail and i call my
parents hi mom hi roland how are you
i've been better i'm in jail jail what
did you do
arson grand larceny and conspiracy you
could hear the phone go dead on the
other and just the shock as her jaw
dropped open
long story short it's in the book they
put up the bail money i was drummed out
of purdue told i could never come back i
was drummed out of the service
said it would be a dishonorable
discharge
and i was a free man
so to speak
but i had no future there what i had to
do then is i had to go to europe my
first mission that was explained to me
would take me to the middle east
so i applied to the university in munich
because being fluent in german of german
parentage it was very easy for me to get
in
an interesting thing about european at
least german universities at the time is
they don't test they don't test you in
any courses you take
until it's time for you to graduate
which makes for a very interesting
scenario after four years in college
when a lot of kids get a call from their
parents saying aren't you graduating
this year and oh my god
because then you have to take a test on
every course you ever took
but it made it easy for me because all i
had to do was sign up for the classes
and they would stamp the fact that i
signed up in my studio book which is my
book that
my records
and i got credit for the course you
didn't really ever have to show up for
class so all of a sudden i have a great
cover
i go home one day i was living with my
aunt and uncle outside of munich in a
little town called underfattenhofen for
those of you who might speak german
that one's even hard for people who
speak german
and i told him that i wanted to go and
see india
and they thought i was crazy to begin
with anyway so sure go ahead
i packed a backpack a sleeping bag and i
headed east i was supposed to go through
turkey
iran afghanistan
pakistan
india and then return and i had various
things i was supposed to do on the way
there and on the way back
it was an easy thing to do back then
nowadays you couldn't do something like
that people come up to me and they say
you know if you have done all these
things like the
targeted killings etc removing people
why don't they just send someone like
you in to get osama bin laden
well easier said than done you have to
understand in the 70s
it was uh very popular for westerners
so-called hippies at the time
to hitch to india along what was called
uh
the hippie trail the drug trail whatever
they were all over it was easy for a
person like me to function
in
afghanistan in iran because
iran and afghanistan were allies of the
u.s at the time i remember being in
tehran iran
sitting in a bar can't do that today
and in the bar on the tv was payton
place
certainly can't do that today
today if i were to show up in a place
like iran or afghanistan they would
shoot me
before they would ask me any questions
just because of the way i look there is
no trust left anymore
well i went through i got to turkey
first istanbul and set up the contacts i
was supposed to set up didn't do take
any overt action at the time
and then continued eastward
my first actual
action for the mission here came in
kabul afghanistan there was a major drug
lord
and he was targeted for removal by the
cia
now did i ask why
no that's not that wasn't my place
i just knew it had to happen
after having set up the required
contacts in the certain amount of time
and gaining the trust
we agreed to meet in the kabul hotel
where i was supposed to kill him
which brings me to i just want to
digress for a second the subtitle of the
book says cia assassin
assassin is certainly a very very
provocative word it's not a word i would
have chosen it's a word a publisher
chooses because he likes to sell lots of
books and it gets people's attention
if you take a soldier and give that
soldier a weapon
and send him out into the field into a
war zone and say your mission which is
the mission of every soldier is to
kill the enemy whether it's shoot 300
yards downrange if you tell a pilot he's
supposed to drop a bomb on a target if
you tell a tanker he's supposed to lob a
shell
however far downrange do you call those
people
assassins or murderers i understand
there are some people who will say yes i
take new issue with them you know that's
personal
choice
but you generally just call them
soldiers some of them get medals some of
them get pats on the back whatever
my job was to go into places where you
could not send a person in a uniform
because he would stick out too much
where you had to go in individually
one-on-one
well one-on-one would have been great
except this guy showed up at the hotel
with two bodyguards
two brothers
people say how did you plan for things
like this well it's really hard to plan
for pulling a mission in kabul
afghanistan because you never know
what's going to happen and having three
people show up
certainly was uh like throwing a bucket
of cold water in my face
regardless
i had the element of surprise
and
as often the element of luck
behind me i look back and a lot of times
people say also you must be very good at
what you do well
training and being good is only one
small part of it luck
plays a really big role how many times i
think back could have been different if
somebody would have just turned the
corner when they weren't supposed to if
six people would have shown up at this
site instead of three three was bad
enough
in any case
i was able to accomplish that mission i
won't go into gory details here it is in
the book
and at that point
my life was changed forever because
there are a lot of things you can take
back in this life
if you steal something you can give it
back
if you hurt somebody you can make amends
but once you've taken a life
you can't restore that life
it didn't bother me at first there
really was no time to be bothered about
it because if you stop to think am i
doing the right thing
then it's then you become the target
all of a sudden
you're the target and they are the
people carrying it out
i was lucky i got away
went into pakistan and then into india
on the way back my next mission was
supposed to be in turkey coming home
i was very naive i was supposed to find
my own way over and my own way back
again to provide cover and i did that by
hitchhiking which back then was very
easy
i caught a ride with somebody out of new
delhi a guy named eric
who was a uh
he wanted to be a documentary filmmaker
and he was shooting a lot of footage he
had a mercedes van what i did not know
and talk about irony of ironies i was
sent to take out
drug lords he was smuggling drugs
in the panels of the van
we hit the iranian border and there's a
nice sign on the iranian border that
says if you are caught with any drugs or
contraband you will be shot
no ifs ands or butts
they were expecting him they'd been
tipped off
and the two of us got arrested
it was quite a shock
taken off to a prison
close to the border where we were
supposed to sign confessions
the confessions were written out in
persian farsi i don't do persian farsi
and i knew the minute i signed anything
i was a dead man
eric signed very quickly and eric became
dead very quickly he was killed
i underwent several days
as you heard of what can be called
extreme torture i was beaten
beaten senseless
uh i took my daily feces and urine
showers because any time i relieved
myself in the bucket of this little very
small cell that you couldn't even move
in they'd come in and pour the bucket
over my head
and every day they'd ask me to sign and
every day i'd say no
it culminated in me being told they
weren't going to fool around anymore i'd
been found guilty and i was going to be
executed
i was taken out in the courtyard of the
prison
put up against the wall chained to the
wall
facing a firing squad
ready aim fire in persian farsi but you
kind of know what's going on even if you
don't understand the words here
and they shot on both sides of my head
real bullets
at that point i passed out because if
you don't think that's going to mess
with your head
surprise it really does
interestingly and what really worked to
my advantage here again like i said the
iranians were
allies of the us the savak the secret
police had been trained by the central
intelligence agency and when they made
drug arrests especially involving
americans they would report this to the
central intelligence agency just so they
could keep track of who had been
arrested who had been executed etc
it took him over a week to get my name
to the right people who said hey wait a
minute he's one of ours
i woke up in a small
hotel
i was
cleanly washed shaven and my clothes
were pressed and ready
i could hardly walk
when i left germany
i weighed about 225 pounds i was a
competitive
bodybuilder and power lifter along with
what i was doing
by the time i left that iranian prison
it was closer to 150.
i was a mere skeleton and i'm not saying
this for pity i mean
i did things i understand that and there
were consequences for these things in
this case i was on the wrong end of the
punishment scale
i could hardly walk i walked with a limp
and i still had more of this mission to
carry out in turkey and i wondered how
this was going to happen
i caught another ride
ended up in istanbul
and once again
the mission went off a lot better this
time
i'm skipping parts here because it's a
longer book than the time i've got to
speak
after this
i was not used for targeted
assassinations or targeted killings for
a while i was used to
again having spoken russian
to get people out of east germany
to the west
that was a lot more fulfilling to me
because i didn't have to kill anybody
nobody likes doing that
but even after a while doing that i
thought you know my whole life has
actually been a search for normalcy
i wanted to be normal and what i was
doing was anything but normal
so i went to my handler
who by the way checked in with me
regularly i never knew how to get in
touch with them
they always got in touch with me
and said i wanted to go back to purdue
but i realized the futility of that i
was drummed out told never to come back
and i had a police record full of
felonies
and i said well
go ahead and apply
i applied
not only was i taken back i was given a
full scholarship made a dorm counselor
and no longer had a police record and by
the way got an honorable discharge in
the mail
just to show you what they can do if
they really want to
went back to purdue finished up a
bachelor's finished up a masters in
german and russian and then went off to
do a doctorate in comparative literature
at berkeley
while there i opened a health club again
i was looking for normalcy and
unfortunately one of the people that
started working at my club was named
sunny barger
if the name doesn't ring a bell i just
looked at his book staring me in the
face two aisles down he's the president
of the hell's angels
he gave my partner a loan of a lot of
money in cash
and if you know the hell's angels they
don't do anything for free
they owned my partner and one day they
told me that i would now be working for
them
they would take over the books and the
club and they would pay me a salary well
i didn't like that idea
i was a lot bigger and a lot dumber
and i
told sonny he'd have to leave
that's putting it nicely
i was shot soon after that twice i lost
most of my middle finger this is sewn
back on i was standing on a third floor
balcony
of my now wife's apartment looking down
and i saw someone with the rifle aimed
up at me he wasn't aiming at my hand i
did one of these things
and boom shot ran out fingers are gone
it was time to leave the country again
so i went back to germany
and
once again
who falls and stepped next to me
good old phil my handler
and again
they had need of me this time
in the early 80s
late 70s early 80s i don't know how many
of you have lived in germany or how many
of you are familiar with this but the
red army faction was very
active
these what this was a communist group
and one thing they did is they would
kill american soldiers their families
they would set bombs up in pxs exchanges
shopping areas
and what they would do is one of the
modus operandi they used was they would
use some
very good-looking
young ladies to try and seduce
american soldiers in bars in frankfurt
now
how hard a mission do you think it is to
seduce
an american soldier in a bar in
frankfurt
it's really easy okay they get them
drunk they get them back to wherever
they're going promises of a night of a
lot of fun and then they kill them and
then they've got their ids
and they now have access to american
facilities and the bombs go off
authorities
had gotten a tip to who these
three young ladies in this operation
were and they took off for east germany
we knew they were planning more
operations but here again you cannot
send soldiers
into uh an east block country for lord's
sake like east germany and have them do
anything so i was sent in
and my next mission was to eliminate
these three young ladies now here again
people say how can you
how can you kill
a young lady how can you kill any woman
or a child
but
again this was a wartime target
if you were to stop and they came back
bombs go off in frankfurt and a great
number of people are killed i didn't
question i just did what i was told that
was my mission
life went on like that for quite a while
doing some non-lethal things too again
like was mentioned uh
helping soviet specinez officers defect
and that was interesting because i took
one battalion commander from spetsnaz
unit and his uh executive officer and
brought him back
and they brought the soviet war plans
for the fulda gap which is where i was
operating out of and wouldn't you know
it but their war plans totally
invalidated all the planning that the us
and germany had done
for a couple decades already and how
they were going to defend the fulda gap
and go in in case of war
life seemed to be good
but
the life i was living took a toll in
that
i started thinking more and more about
what i had done because however i might
sound up here in describing these things
i was not without feeling
and i really wasn't inhuman and it got
to the point
that i couldn't even go to sleep at
night without taking a couple drinks to
forget about what i had done because i
always had these faces and these
these happenings in my head
and it got to the point where a couple
drinks wouldn't do it anymore i had to
have more than a couple of drinks and
then it got to the point where i could
actually polish off
a whole bottle of vodka and we're not
talking the 80 proof we're talking the
50 vodka which is a hundred proof i
could drink the bottle
i could talk to you i could function
and soon after that i would pass out and
again that's what i was after
it seemed to me that what i was doing
was committing suicide by alcohol i just
couldn't continue
when you have a top secret clearance and
work for the government
you are not allowed at least until
recently you have not been allowed to
seek help if you've got a psychological
problem with something because all of a
sudden you become a bad risk which means
although you're trying to find help
you are now blackmailable if you're
blackmailable you can't have a top
secret clearance if you don't have a
clearance you lose your job
and we find this a lot with soldiers
that return from a war theater what they
call post-traumatic stress everything is
bottled up inside till it gets to the
point where they might shoot up a
building who knows what will happen with
me it was self-destructive and
like i said i sank further and further
into that and occurred to me one day you
know i've got to stop this this is
killing me
and then came the next shock i couldn't
i if i tried not to drink for a few
hours i would start getting the shakes i
i would become
life was unlivable so i had to drink
more i became reconciled to the fact
that perhaps this was my penance this
was my punishment and this is how i was
going to die i just didn't want to get
off the couch anymore
one night after passing out in bed i got
up for a drink late at night
and i missed the top step
live on the second floor
fell down 12 stairs i always thought
that was interesting the alcoholic falls
down 12 steps
it was like you know there really is a
god up there and he's saying look i've
been trying to tell you over and over
that this is not a good idea
you're not listening let's try this
i broke
my right wrist
several ribs and all the bones in my
face
and in the hospital i developed lung
problems
and almost died in and out of
consciousness for quite some time
i've had it said to me boy you're lucky
you got to go through uh withdrawal
while being unconscious you didn't feel
the effects baloney
i can recount virtually i couldn't move
couldn't feed myself i can recount
the dreams i had they were horrible
and they all involved always ended in my
slow death i mean i just lived hell
for a long time
as the poisons got out of my system
when i finally was able to leave the
hospital it was not under my own power
because i'd been in bed so long i
couldn't even take a step
on my own i had to be taught re-taught
how to walk i couldn't feed myself i
would miss my mouth i would dribble
to take a guy who'd worked 30 years for
central intelligence who wanted to be a
marine
who was gung-ho
who came in in the top 10 in the world
in power lifting
and then he's down
literally to a skeleton my clothes just
hung on me
worst punishment i could think of
when i finally went back to a gym i
couldn't lift 10 pounds over my head and
i sat there and i cried
because i see all these people who used
to see me when i
really looked like something
and they're all looking away they don't
want to make eye contact
uh they're pitying me
and i thought of all that i'd lost but
then i thought well you know i can go
home
i can lie back down i can start drinking
that vodka again and i can finish the
job or i can take that 10 pounds and
lift it till i can do 15 till i can do
20.
and i worked it back up to over 400 on a
bench press and i'm 55 that's pretty
good if you're 25
but it was just something that i knew i
had to do
during this whole time
my family had no idea
what i was doing
people say was your wife an idiot
no my wife is sitting out here so i'm
not going to call her an idiot but she
is really intelligent really and uh
one time i had again soviets but snazz
officers the handoff went bad and i had
to take him to our house
and she came to the house and here are
these soviets sitting in the living room
with german special forces because i
called them to make the handoff and she
wanted to know what was going on
and i said well it's simple i was in
downtown folden i ran into these
russians they didn't speak german or
english and i speak russian so i thought
i'd help him out
now before you think
she's an idiot
what was she supposed to think oh my god
my husband must be in the cia
which is even more absurd
i always had a job
that covered me going someplace being
away from home for a certain amount of
time there was always a logical and
rational explanation for why i wasn't at
home
so my family didn't know my kids
certainly didn't know
and
which kind of brings us up to today i
wrote the book for a number of reasons
a was cathartic
i had to get it out
i had no intention of widespread
publication when i wrote this
i wrote it for my family so they would
know what i'd been because i thought how
tragic would it be
both my parents died
before they could find out what i had
really done
so they lived with that shame
that i was the only son the only boy in
the extended family who did not come
through everybody else had good jobs
they were teachers they were tradesmen
and then there was roland who was thrown
out
that was tragic enough
but i thought with the number of times
that i almost died had i died without my
family
my wife and my kids knowing the only
memory they would have had left of me
was that broken down old drunk sitting
on the couch who didn't want to get up
anymore
so it was cathartic it was to let them
know what i had done
and the third reason one of the guys i
work out with at the gym and play
racquetball with and this is a little
embarrassing
he's in his 70s
and during the korean war he served in
they dropped him behind the lines in
north korea he was one of the first
special operations soldiers for the army
working with the cia
and he said you know roland he wrote a
book he said you really have to put this
down
for a historical record
you don't break confidence you don't
tell secrets you don't divulge current
operations sources and methods
but i want you to do this and i said but
ben
his name's ben malcolm and i think his
book is here too it's called white
tigers
i said what will the cia say they want
to read everything before you publish it
he said you don't show it to him
pure and simple he said when i did it i
sent him the book and they told me you
can't write that
and i asked them why is it classified
they said no it never happened
well they even gave him the silver star
and they changed the citation because
they couldn't admit where this happened
so he went back and said well if it
didn't happen i can write about it
correct and i said
no you can't write about it
because it never happened and he went
through this do loop for two or three
years before before he finally said the
heck with it i'm gonna write it anyway
and he uh encouraged me to do the same
thing
saying that the three options for the
cia today with me are
a to flat out call me a liar and hope i
don't have the proof
and they don't want to push that button
b is to prosecute
and try and stop publication of the book
in which case they give me so much
publicity
it's kind of counterproductive to what
they want to do
and the third option is benign neglect
pretend i don't exist and hope nobody
buys the book and then it quietly fades
away
so far the response has been benign
neglect
and i'm hoping that's the way it's going
to continue because all this time if
they were to come back now and say none
of this happened by the way i've just
been invited to speak by the department
of the navy
on a destroyer
next to wash in washington out just
outside of washington about cold war and
cold war tactics these are the guys
remember who threw me out
and have now come back and acknowledged
yes he's real yes he was one of ours and
we want him to speak
so it's going to be harder and harder
for anyone to say
you know it never happened
so that's where we are that's where i
came with enter the past tense the title
is simple when i was 18 19 when i was
first recruited the person i had been
the roland haas i had been ceased to
exist he literally entered the past
tense
after i
had my first
after the first killings in afghanistan
you see i even have a hard time saying
it
i went even further into the past tense
because who i was psychologically who i
was spiritually emotionally that person
died too
and marched off into the past tense
and there we have it do i have any
questions
i'm sure we do
oh and we do have a microphone right
here in the center of the floor here
very careful
okay well i'm sure that'll happen too
yes ma'am there's a microphone right
there i can take this downstairs and
pay for it right here downstairs you can
pay for it later on the way out i guess
your question i'm only up to page 40 but
you referred to it as luck earlier in
your speech and then later on you
referred to a a as an act of god in
falling down the steps do you still
believe things that happened in the past
were just luck or do you believe in
angels and god and it wasn't just luck
well that's an interesting question i
can't say i'm a religious person i am a
spiritual person
one thing that i did not bring up here
because it's one of those things that
make people think that i might be kind
of loony
when i was in the rehab center down in
atlanta one day they took my whole ward
of people put them into vans and took
them out to an a meeting across the
other side of town
when we got back
the nurse on duty who knew nothing about
me
said oh roland you got a phone call well
my wife had been calling my kids had
been calling someone from work was
calling we got a phone call your mother
called and wanted to know how you were
doing
and she said just tell him i called my
mother had died exactly a year before
that
now if i would have gotten that call
people would have said he's delusional
i didn't take that call i never talked
to this person
the nurse took the call and when i said
are you sure she said she was my mother
she said frail voice european accent
and you know it's kind of the thing that
my mother would do
i remember when i first did my first
cruise out of san diego
like most sailors again i had a little
bit too much drink and i was going to
get a tattoo and i called my mother who
lived in ohio
from a phone booth in san diego and said
mom i'm getting a tattoo
she said where are you i set a phone
booth on a pier in san diego she said
give me 10 minutes i'll be there
it sobered me up
and i never got the tattoo
i can't explain that call to the rehab
center because i'm not i'm not trying to
proselytize or convince anybody of
anything but again i didn't get the call
that person who took the call ended up
quitting
she never got she said she couldn't get
over the fact she kept saying i talked
to a dead person i mean she was ashen
and all the people who were on this
little excursion with me they said their
hair stood up and it was very strange
so do i believe there are outside forces
definitely i do do i think
that because i'm here these outside
forces
support
what i did or support what the
government does absolutely not i'm not
one to think that god supports this war
or that war this side or that side for a
guy who's very gung-ho and i still am
i'm also very anti-war
i just think that sometimes there's no
other way to settle things
i have to think some things were luck
because again the mission in turkey i
had to break into a house and
if someone would have just turned the
corner in a car
they would have seen that you can't plan
for things like that uh yet a lot of it
there has to be luck
and there's also bad luck again when the
car does turn the corner
sure
yes did you happen to see or do you
relate to the born ultimatum
yeah if you could use the microphones it
would be easier to hear this have i seen
or do i relate to the born ultimatum
i have not that's the new one correct i
have not seen the movie
you know one one person had a criticism
who i've talked to about the book so far
and what she said was she expected more
intrigue more and again i finished the
sentence for you mean james bond
and she said yeah yeah that stuff
because to her the reality was the
beauty of a life like this is the fact
that i probably slept with 24 beautiful
russian spies didn't happen at least
it's not in the book
but my wife also knows and there are
some people looking at this book for a
possible movie if it ever makes it to a
movie i'll bet you those 24 beautiful
russian spies are in there
and they're going to be doing things
i've only heard of
but that's just the way it is can i
relate to that
to the extent i saw the earlier born
movies to the extent that i worked
totally alone and trusted nobody
that i can relate with it's been said
that
any three people can keep a secret as
long as two of them are dead
very true statement i the reason i'm
still here is i never ever ever there's
not a club there's not a bar you can go
to with a bunch of old field agents
and discuss what you did that just
doesn't exist
when my wife hears me speak at these
things she's always surprised because
she thought i only knew 10 words
for our whole married life my
and i know a lot of ladies complain
about communication in a marriage but
let me tell you i took that to new lows
i was
i'm fine yep nope
okay
and that's and i have proof of that
because i have an african grey parrot at
home who listened to me answer the phone
one day
and i said hello
if you waited a second yep
yep
okay goodbye now when the phone rings
this idiot parrot goes hello
with the same timing yep
and in my voice yep
okay goodbye it's like he's mocking me
and here again it's almost like we were
talking about before you know the luck
or the outside forces this parrot
reminds me
so
so that's about the most i can relate to
that
yes if you could use the mic or he'll
even bring you one
um some of the stupidest things i've
ever said in my life were after a couple
of drinks yes
so how in the world did you keep from
blabbing after drinking a whole bottle
of vodka
the fact that i didn't speak goes back
to my earliest childhood
when my when i was born and my folks
were living in buffalo and we spoke only
german
we lived in a ghetto in buffalo
and what most kids wanted to do was what
their father did which was kill a nazi
and looking around i was the only one
around you know being german
they didn't know it but i've got a good
percentage jewish blood in me too but
the fact was i was german so if i opened
my mouth i got beaten up
every day
of my life so i stopped talking you know
it's like pavlov's dogs it doesn't take
too many times of being beaten up when
you know speak beating don't speak might
live
i was beaten so bad once that i had my
appendix ruptured and got rushed to the
hospital kids
when i describe some of these things you
might think it's cruel what adults do
kids can be so much crueler than adults
i had it ingrained in me even when i
went out to drink and i seldom drank
outside of the home
again for that very reason because i did
not want to slip but i didn't say
anything i only listened and that was
again because of what happened to me as
a child and later it was good training
it it served me well not to speak
he's coming with the microphone
now the way you describe it in more ways
than one you shouldn't be here yes one
thing is that you try to kill yourself
but also that they wouldn't want you to
be here
um i sense some anger is that directed
at yourself or at the agency because
they
made you that kind of person or
first of all i don't blame anybody for
the fact that i became an alcoholic
i have
first of all genetic predisposition as
we know it is a genetic disease and i'm
not blaming my parents there either what
happened to me happened because i took
those drinks nobody forced me that was
my choice out
as far as the agency
here's the other reason for writing the
book
well i did talk to a handler before i
started writing the book and not about
the book but just saying you know i'm
getting on in years now what kind of
retirement plan do i have
and he just shook his head and i said
what do you mean
with this he said well
if we were to give you a retirement it's
an acknowledgement
that you work for us
my thoughts were
the job i'm in now assistant deputy
chief of staff for intelligence for a
major army command when i got that job i
was not qualified for it it's the agency
that arranged for that job 15 years ago
14 years ago if they can arrange to get
me a job that i'm not qualified for why
couldn't they back date
when i started officially working for
the government so i turned to him and i
say well what am i supposed to do about
retirement
and this is the line that really got me
the big slap in the face and there are a
lot stronger words than that
we hear kmart's hiring
now
after going through what i'd gone
through and done what i had done to be
told and there's nothing wrong with
working at kmart but what i had gone
through and what i thought i was doing
and contributing to be told that i would
spend my old age
handing out carts and greeting people as
they came in the door
that was just a little bit rough and i
thought to myself okay i'm gonna handle
my own retirement
under these circumstances and again
another reason for writing the book
could you discuss the rigors of the
training and
how long it took and
it was and what typically occurred in
the training process
well to be trained in weapons
familiarization and how to disable and
kill an opponent
if you do it correctly
nowadays you can go into a karate studio
you can work three years and get a black
belt and never get a black eye
didn't work for me
you know you got beaten up heavily
because if you make a mistake it's
costly and they try to ingrain that into
you i remember uh
initial boxing training
when i'm standing there and the guy boom
before i even got my hands up hit me
square in the face and near knocked me
out i said what was that
i wasn't ready he said
always be ready
always have your hands up couldn't you
have told me that
he said well if i would have told you
that you probably wouldn't have
remembered it
you're probably going to remember this
the the parachute training yeah also
rigorous like i said
i did my final call at the final exam
work at the yuma proving grounds
out in yuma
why it's named that
where i would be dropped and i had to
make my way back to a certain collection
point
you know just land navigation etc
and it was rigorous training certainly
mr haas
i have a great deal of respect for what
you did and i i am
grateful that there are people like you
in this country
and i
i remember you said
at the age of 19 you were approached by
suits
and since then you've never trusted
anybody how did you trust them to begin
with and know that they were the right
three-letter people
the right cia i mean you we see so many
and here's so many stories about
people who are double agents who
disguise themselves as other agents how
did you trust them to begin with
well first of all the training that they
outlined that i was going to do happened
at various military installations
so
that kind of puts something in their
favor
and then there has to be an element of
trust
for that
and third
the hook was they appealed
to something in me that was never really
appeased before remember i had no
friends as a child
the sports i did were all individual
sports because when it came time to pick
up teams
everybody would be taken and i'd be left
standing there alone
here was a guy who came up to me and
said
not just we're from the government trust
us but we're from the government and we
think
you
have the qualities we need
to help the country now for a 19 year
old who's gung-ho that's a hell of a
hook
you know it
and i don't blame them for that i mean
it's recruiting what can i say but it
really
they had me at hello what can i say the
way that song works
they had me at hello i thought i could
do something for them and they wanted
me
i fit the total profile of what they
wanted the loner multilingual athletic
my brain was a lot better than before i
doused it with alcohol i never took a
book home in high school or junior high
and got straight a's i tested out of two
and a half years of college before i
even got there
ap chemistry physics
calculus
sociology anthropology
uh four years of german because i could
open a book read it and take a test
and these were all things that they were
looking for so i feel the need they had
and they certainly filled a need that i
had
it doesn't
from from what i hear
on on the news
about
uh our soldiers going to afghanistan or
going to iraq and none of them speak the
language they
they're given little cards saying you
know uh this is what you say to a woman
this is what you don't say to a woman i
mean it's it's like we've lost the
ability to
hire people like you
i don't think it's the fact that we've
lost the ability
think about what you're saying when i
went in they were looking for people who
i spoke
german russian i had 12 years of latin
which gave me a basis in the romance
languages and we still have those people
today what we do not have are arabic
speakers
the us is not prepared for the situation
we're in today because we never
envisioned
conflict
in the arab world
and what high school teaches arabic
languages
what college actually teaches arabic
languages my brother went to indiana
university he took chinese and some
arabic but you know
there aren't that many of them
and again
if you're going to hire a person who has
some native ability a young person in
these arabic languages then you have the
trust factor are you going to give them
a top secret clearance when they still
have family living in the middle east
you know i've been told and i've had to
recruit linguists well why don't we just
go out and get some of the cab drivers
you're not going to get them security
clearances though
our biggest source for linguists now
competent linguists is the mormon faith
in salt lake city because they train
missionaries to go everywhere and so
they have people that speak
most languages but here again just
speaking arabic wouldn't be enough today
i could walk in being totally fluent in
arabic look at me
it's gray now but it was blonde you know
they they'd shoot me before they'd ask
me a question
there's no reason to trust me just
because i speak the language
i could pass for russian i could pass
for german and in the middle east i
could pass for an american hippie with
money who wanted to set up major drug
deals
i could do those things
how do you feel about the quality of the
cia's clandestine service officers today
and is it really true that there is no
retirement program for clandestine
action officers well i can't speak for
anybody else i don't know you have to
understand cia is a massive organization
you can work for the agency in a number
of different capacities you can work in
the building certainly you would then
have a retirement program you can be a
an analyst you could do country guides
country studies you could do target
planning
how they use other what we called human
intelligence human elements i don't know
i can only speak for myself i'm not
going to speculate because again it's
interesting the gym i work out at a lady
came up to me the other day and said my
brother retired from the cia i said good
she said and he said he doesn't know you
oh well okay
i don't know him either but no but you
don't understand he's he's really high
up and he knows everybody and he went
through the
employment files and didn't find your
name
i knew right away there was no point in
arguing with this lady what you have to
understand is intelligence at that level
is what we call compartmentalized
nobody but nobody in the agency has an
overview of everything everybody has
pieces of a puzzle
and to say that my brother knows
everything and then the other thing that
occurred to me is well look lady your
brother's in the cia he knows everybody
and he just told you i'm not an agent
this is the kind of guy we don't want in
the cia he talks too much
uh so is there a retirement plan i
suppose for some people there are sure
for me and it might also have to do with
the fact that remember i was not just a
person who was passing information back
and forth and gathering information
i was used for something that until very
recently and by recently i mean within
the last month or so
that the us government denied we ever
did which is targeted killings in 1976
gerald ford signed an executive order
that said nobody that works for the us
will indulge in targeted killings of
foreign
people
that was reiterated by carter in 78 and
later on by reagan
now the interesting thing about an
executive order is it's not a law it's a
strong suggestion for people who work in
the executive
branch of the government
but it appeases the american people
we somehow think as americans that when
we fight a war
we do it nicely we do it cleanly and we
follow the rules
you don't win a war war is dirty war is
not nice and there are no rules look
what happened to the british when they
marched on america in 1776 the americans
were hiding behind trees shooting at
them and picking them off and they were
called dirty fighters that's the only
way you win the war
americans find it very convenient to
believe that we would never do something
like targeted killings but
you have to be totally naive it's a fact
of life it has to be done
and when i say it has to be done again
just think of what if somebody could
have taken out the people who did pull
off 911 how many lives would have been
saved by killing one two three
eight people however many were involved
it doesn't make it any nicer and i
wouldn't i don't say it's something that
anybody can do
i saw a movie called the sin eater
and in the sin eater what happens is
it's an old tradition that when a person
dies they did this in england in various
places you would call in the sin eater
and he would eat a sumptuous banquet
next to the coffin or off of the coffin
of the dead person
thereby symbolically turkey taking on
that person's sins so that person could
go to heaven
without retribution i often considered
myself a sin eater it's something that
nobody wants to do
but somebody had to do it
in my opinion and again the question was
asked how do i know they were real
well i had to i trusted them i had to
trust them if i would have questioned
them i would have gone crazy a lot
sooner
hang on you got a microphone coming
oh
yeah in iraq
we have many of these roadside
bombs being blowing up their
troops as they're passing by
is there any and with the technology
that there is today
they can only they can stay in their way
a mile away
and press a button and
this
bomb would go off is there any way of
intercepting this to some degree or
can't it be
absolutely not there is no way that you
can detect a roadside bomb an ied
uh any of those things and here again
then we have americans saying they're
fighting dirty well they're fighting
with the only means they have now i have
seen you know tapes taken from
attack helicopters that when we do spot
these people
planting these bombs we shoot a missile
at them
uh
any of you who've seen james bond movies
or war movies and think when you get
shot you fall down and die you ought to
see what happens to a person when he
shot by a 50 caliber from a helicopter
he literally blows up
and
if this were shown on the nightly news
there would be a lot of outrage but what
do you do let them plant that roadside
bomb and take out god knows how many
people
no there is no technology for detecting
that
absolutely none
okay we have time for one more question
i'll let the man with the microphone
decide oh let's make it to their two
hands up
with the book
do you have any worry about looking over
your shoulder that there are a lot of
black
black-headed guys out there that uh
might want to
even the score
i don't because
the things i describe in the book i cut
off
the description of my operations with
the early or mid 90s for a reason
a i don't want to give away classified
information the number of reasons for
that one is integrity i don't want to
compromise any current mission sources
methods and two and i always say this is
i have been offered tremendous amounts
of money
by various big-name publishers to go
public
with things that would embarrass
uh high-ranking american officials
beyond integrity what that means is i
would make a lot of money and my wife
would be collecting it while i'm in jail
i don't you know i love her but
i don't want to do that either
the missions i describe the targeted
assassinations the killings all took
place in regimes that no longer exist
when i was in iran the shah was in power
gone when i was in afghanistan my god
we've gone through a couple of regimes
since then you know the soviets the
soviets marched in soon after i left
there and
now it's just mayhem
what are the odds of an afghani
tribesman who's growing poppies who lost
a grandfather 30 years ago reading in
the paper about me
not very likely
i worked heavily in east germany that
wall came down now
the government is starting to release
stasi files i am very confident that i
exist in stasi files and someday that
will be released
i went to a folks march with my family
in germany and there was a guy taking
pictures of the folks march he'd be
aimed over here i'm sitting there and as
he's taking his picture
he kept turning
and clicking on me
that was very obvious you know when you
take half a roll of film or a roll of
film on me during a folk's march
east german agent but that regime
doesn't exist anymore either
so if anybody maybe the hell's angels
but they've got enough trouble now with
the drug enforcement agency having
infiltrated almost every chapter they've
got and facing so many indictments they
don't need me to show up dead anywhere
you know it would just be too obvious
right now and i never i never squealed
on them
because the deal the government offered
me to squeal on them wasn't much better
they offered me witness protection
program
saying they might guarantee me life for
another two to three years before i were
found and killed i said nah
not a good deal so i i didn't talk
yes in the final question
excuse me
i have a lot of friends that are special
ops because i had a lot of military
training and their role seemed to be
similar uh one worked for the state
department another was navy seal another
was special forces officer
and it seems to me that the operations
are parallel
and i'm wondering whether they work
as operatives with the cia or in
conjunction with operations so people
don't
bump into each other
in
behind the scenes
the cia does use highly trained people
from the various uniformed services like
i said even going back to the korean war
my friend ben malcolm he was a second
lieutenant freshly commissioned in the
army when he was offered this
opportunity to go into north korea
and he took it
you know again a crazy guy crazy
childhood just thought hey this is going
to be fun and in his book he talks about
you know running gun battles with north
koreans robbing banks
nifty things like that so yes the agency
does employ
and
i don't see many of these movies but one
i did see recently was called the
shooter with ken wahlberg and here again
he was a millet mark wahlberg wallenberg
uh he was a military sharpshooter sniper
that was on a cia operation where they
weren't supposed to be and by the way
that describes almost every cia
operation
which again reminds me another reason
for not writing over the past decade
if it's a domestic operation it belongs
to the fbi if it's foreign it belongs to
the cia i worked for the cia if i were
ever to talk about or even hint at
operations in the u.s
opens up a whole can of worms and these
intelligence agencies hate each other
they don't work well together they don't
play nice
the fbi would rather see the cia fail
and the cia would rather see the fbi
fail than to stop a major operation if
they can't get the credit
nobody should get the credit
and that's it thanks for coming folks i
hope i answered your questions for you
[Applause]
enter the past tense my secret life as a
cia assassin roland haas is an assistant
deputy chief of staff and the command
senior intelligence officer of the u.s
army reserve command
for more information visit the military
reserve at army reserve dot army dot m i
l
[Music]